könnten diese antibiotika endlich die
multiresistenten keime stoppen
es sind ja nicht nur viren sondern auch
resistente bakterien die unsere welt von
jetzt auf gleich völlig lahmlegen
könnten vor allem hartnäckige
multiresistente krankenhauskeime machen
den fachleuten sorge denn sie könnten
für zehn millionen tote pro jahr sorgen
doch jetzt gibt es einen durchbruch eine
neue klasse von antibiotika zieht mit
einem völlig neuen wirkungsmechanismus
in den kampf gegen die erreger wird er
erfolgreich sein krieg zum science
fiction gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen klicks um
science-fiction gibt es jetzt übrigens
auch als podcast für unterwegs also
unten in der video beschreibung die
links zu spotify oder apple music
anklicken und loslegen mit dem klick zum
podcast wir sehen es gerade für uns
unsichtbare viren können von jetzt auf
gleich die welt verändern in der wir
leben doch es sind nicht nur viren von
denen eine echt globale bedrohung
ausgeht multiresistente keime die von
den vereinten nationen als die größte
und dringendste gefahr überhaupt
bezeichnet werden ab dem jahr 2050
könnten es pro jahr zehn millionen tote
durch resistente keime seien
es scheint so als seien wir diesen
superkeim schutzlos ausgeliefert bereits
heute sterben immer wieder menschen
unter den augen von ärzteteams an
bakteriellen infektion und das obwohl
ein antibiotikum nach dem anderen
verabreicht wird dennoch entwickeln
pharmaunternehmen weltweit kaum noch
neue wirkstoffe die dagegen wirken
könnten die forschung an neuen
antibiotika wird teilweise sogar
gestoppt und das obwohl die zahl
resistenter keime zunimmt das problem
die forschung in diesem bereich ist im
vergleich zu anderen bereichen nicht
wirklich profitabel zeitgleich
entwickeln viele bakterielle erreger
resistenzen gegen gleich mehrere
antibiotika klassen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who warnt
vor allem vor gramnegativen bakterien
die gegen sogenannte carbapeneme und
cephalosporin antibiotika immun sind
nicht einmal mehr cool ist ihnen ein
antibiotikum was eigentlich nur als
reserve mittel dient kommt gegen diese
bakteriellen erreger an doch diese
führen zu lebensbedrohlichen infektion
mit dabei nicht nur blutvergiftungen
also setzte sondern auch lungen und
hirnhautentzündungen das ist wirklich
so glauben aber die letzte neue klasse
von antibiotika die gegen diese erreger
entwickelt wurde kam bereits in den 60er
jahren auf dem markt seitdem quasi
stillstand doch ein forschungsteam aus
der schweiz meldet jetzt einen
entscheidenden erfolg die forscher haben
eine neue familie von synthetischen
antibiotika aufgespürt dazu john
robinson der an der studie beteiligt war
die neuen antibiotika interagieren mit
proteinen der außenmembran von
gramnegativen bakterien nach unseren
ergebnissen binden die antibiotika
einerseits an fett ähnliche membran
komponenten den sogenannten
lipopolysaccharide und andererseits
anders membranproteinen beim das für den
aufbau der äußeren hülle von
gramnegativen bakterien essentiell ist
heißt also im klartext es handelt sich
um einen völlig neuen
wirkungsmechanismus bisher zählt
tatsächlich keines der entwickelten
antibiotika auf diejenigen proteine ab
die für die außenmembran der bakterien
eine schlüsselrolle spielen dabei ist
die aus membranen so wichtig für die
bakterien denn diese soll sie vor
jeglichen toxischen umweltfaktoren
schützen unter anderem eben auch vor
antibiotika doch genau hier setzen
einige der neu entdeckten substanzen an
sie führen vereinfacht gesagt dazu dass
die erreger platzen und die infektion so
eingedämmt werden kann und diese
strategie zeigt tatsächlich wirkung das
konnten bereits experimente mit
zellkulturen aber auch mit mäusen zeigen
die mit diesen bakterien infiziert
worden waren sogar multi resistente
pathogene konnten bekämpft werden die
substanzen erwiesen sich sogar gegen die
mitglieder der sogenannten escape
erreger wirkungsvoll das steht für eine
gruppe gefährliche krankenhauskeime das
forschungsteam hat jetzt den plan eine
der substanzen schon bald den klinischen
tests an den menschen zu bringen sollten
sich in diesen studien zeigen dass die
wirkstoffe auch im menschlichen körper
wirken wäre dies ein absolut
spektakulärer erfolg dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam in der studie die
übrigens in der renommierten
fachzeitschrift nature veröffentlicht
wurde
dies hätte das potential effektiv gegen
lebensgefährliche infektionen vorgehen
zu können und damit ein dringendes
medizinisches bedürfnis zu erfüllen das
wäre wirklich ein riesenschritt und
erfolg hammer genauso übrigens wie der
kanal ein fach medizin sein video hier
grippe influenza virus symptome
gruppen impfung ist extrem spannend und
informativ also anklicken anschauen und
das ist ein pflicht abo also abonnieren
bis dann bleib dran